two american icons have built a very
close friendship one is a 20-time grammy
winner known for writing the soundtrack
of the working man the other well he's
the 44th president of the united states
in their first joint interview former
president barack obama and bruce
springsteen met up with anthony mason of
course at springsteen's new jersey farm
their new book is called renegades born
in the usa and it comes out on tuesday
it continues the conversations that they
had on the podcast of the very same name
they discussed race the state of the
country the influence of their fathers
and most important how did they become
friends
podcast was your idea
it was you know the the way this came up
we did have a bunch of long
conversations together and i always say
when i first met bruce he's kind of he
seems like
surprisingly shy considering he goes out
there and sings before
tens of thousands of people for hours
at a time yeah and we just ended up
being in settings where we'd have these
long conversations and i thought the
things we're talking about what does it
mean to
be a man what does it mean to be an
american these were things that were
just kind of popping up over a meal or a
drink
and i thought you know what this might
be something that would be useful for
folks to hear because i initially
thought that he had gotten the wrong
number when he called me
to do this yes and as i said okay let me
let me figure this out i am a guitar
playing high school graduate from
freehold new jersey
and uh okay you want me to do what you
know
makes perfect sense to me you can watch
anthony's interview with former
president obama and bruce springsteen
this weekend on cbs sunday morning we'll
have more on monday right here on cbs
mornings i love the two of them together
wouldn't you like to be a fly on the
wall when those two are in the room yeah
absolutely i love the three of them
together yeah trio right yes it's quite
the trio you're right